vous avez demandé un bien sûr que je
fasse le coup de la tarde à on va y
aller tout de suite
allez-y on retrouve le trou de la carte
est ce qu'on peut mettre celle de
bertrand chamerois et de bernard montel
mais quand je mange des partis à la
[ __ ]
alors on y va les chéris aubin voilà
alors au bas voilà on y est là on n'y
est pas alors avant avant je voudrais
dire merci à tous voilà d'abord acte
avec nous ce soir
analyse à faire à bertrand chapron a
encore bon anniversaire à muriel voilà
pour qui je fait saquer dans le public
je voudrais embrasser tout le monde va
se retrouver de badens tout soit à mon
pote à 18h45 heure à les quatre pierres
de jean luc lemoine maire et jean luc
lemoine
merci thierry moreau merci à vous a
dégagé envie de lire c'est partir
c'est bon
quant à votre cache sous la terrasse